throughout cyberpunk we meet a large
cast of characters all with different
personalities and views like misty
jackie's love interest and tarot card
reader or even carrie the lead guitarist
for samurai these two and more make up
the companions of cyberpunk characters
we can do missions for and go on
adventures with today's video we'll be
discussing these characters their
personalities their side missions what
the outcomes of those side missions are
and just an overall analysis of the
character now there is a ton of
characters that exist in this game some
are main characters some are only
accessible during side missions so i
looked through the characters and came
up with a character list of roughly when
we meet them this list includes jackie
judy claire
takamura panam river and carrie i wanted
to add characters like misty and victor
as while they're important as you see
them quite a few times in the game they
don't have too much for you to do for
them misty does have the tarot card
collectible quest but the ending isn't
really too significant besides the heavy
foreshadowing and the endings of the
game
johnny isn't in this video because he's
present for the majority of the game and
because he has so much screen time it's
only fair to give him his own videos
look for a full silverhand deep dive
video in the future as always there's
going to be timestamps on screen in the
description or on the timeline if you
want to skip to a specific character but
if you prefer not to then let's start
with jackie wells
jackie is the first character we come
across in night city depending on the
life path we choose he can either be
already our friend or our enemy no
matter the circumstance you and jackie
become best friends eager to make it to
the top jackie's a guy who values his
friends and family and always puts them
first jackie's a professional when it
comes to mercenary work and has a great
respect for the legends before him
as he constantly praises morgan
blackhand rogue and adam smasher and
calls him the legends of night city
there is a time lapse to solidify this
friendship showing the two going on
missions together all the time
eventually after doing some missions and
gaining some respect popular fixer
dexter deshawn recruits jackie and v to
go on some missions the first two
contracts were just setup missions for
the bigger heist later as we know the
heist goes south causing t-bug and
jackie to both die this is technically
where this would end if not for a future
side mission where you and many of
jackie's friends that have been offering
a memorial for him at the coyote kojo
mama wells calls you and asks you if you
want to attend the funeral should you
accept and you go to jackie's garage and
can see his past along with misty tons
of things are in here his bike rare
tequila motivational posters and an
aquarium there's also a belt that
provides more insight into his father as
we've never heard of him before jackie's
dad used to beat him when he was a child
jackie returned the favor one day and
the next day after his dad left so when
his dad left home
and moved out jackie kept the belt with
him so that when his dad ever returned
he would beat him again with it as
payback you can take some of these items
in here and use them as a memento for
the funeral it doesn't really matter
though as it's just personal choice
afterward you can talk to mama wells
about her attitude towards misty mama
wells never really liked misty saying
that she was never really a good fit for
a girlfriend and that jackie's previous
girlfriend was way better you can talk
her out of this attitude and she
apologizes and then gives you the key to
jackie's bike the ark as a reward for
attending the funeral arc is actually a
real bike company funnily enough owned
by kiana reeves so a nice reference to
the company
there doesn't seem to be a model for the
actual bike in their store but it would
be a really cool purchase to get
jackie's bike in real life so maybe in
the future that'd be a model they
consider producing going back to those
set up missions we meet a woman named
evelyn who introduces us to judy alvarez
a member of the moxes
who runs a braindance studio downstairs
in lizzie's bar while she isn't like the
typical employers the moxes have
sex workers etc she is a brain dance
editor for the moxes which goes hand in
hand with their business which is why
she's a part of them she's always been
hard at work trying to change things for
the gang
nothing like full-on corporate takeovers
but more getting people to respect the
gang as in real life sex work is a
controversial topic and i think that
argument is what created the mox's gang
in the first place for the game
judy introduces us to brain dance on how
to operate them which helps us in the
heist later in the game we end up
needing evelyn's assistance as we need
the biochip out of our head and we can
ask judy for some instructions while she
isn't very pleased she does tell us
about a place called clouds clouds is a
popular nightclub that is known to cater
to client-specific desires so depending
on your specific desire it's like
therapy with a hint of sex appeal there
is an
optional objective to see her booth and
see what happened it seems like she had
her chip malfunctioned during a client
meeting so there seems to be some
intentional fraud going on you find out
through multiple methods she visited
fingers local ripper doc
through braindance activity you find a
factory where she could be hiding we
find her beaten and bruised she is
unresponsive but somewhat conscious so
we take her and dip
we take her to judy's apartment and we
can delve more into her memories thanks
to the brain dance roller she has
installed in her we can use this
opportunity beforehand to go through
judy's apartment where we can see tons
of high-tech equipment and scuba gear
judy managed to salvage some bd content
from her which we use to gain more
context on the whole situation we find
some religious markings that are of
haitian descent as well as a woman with
enough net running skills to hide her
face which could only mean one thing the
voodoo boys they're a gang in pacifica
which is made up of haitian people haiti
before the setting of cyberpunk got hit
with a devastating earthquake that
forced the residents to flee
this created the voodoo boys gang these
seem to be the same people who nuked
evelyn's chip at clouds that we saw all
she was told to do was record a virtue
but as we know from the heist she had
plans to swipe the chip from arasaka
which is not what she was told to do she
was then punished for it later which we
see in that recording the other bd we
have is evelyn spying on someone
which further talks about the chip and
alt cunningham the runner behind the
black wall
this is the last we hear about evelyn
and judy for a little bit as we have
some main quest to do with the voodoo
boys but we don't really care about that
right now later in the game
judy tells us to come to her apartment
and we see evelyn in the tub
she couldn't handle the trauma from the
studio we found her at and she ended her
life we find out that evelyn was raped
and abused by a woodman and then sold
off to the highest bidder once he was
finished with her this then sprouts into
judy's sidequest of getting revenge by
making the mock's employees not have to
deal with this abuse anymore to start we
end up going to the cloud's office and
speaking with one of the head people
maiko something that's slightly shown is
judy smoking in the scene with evelyn
she asks for some smokes she mentioned
that she quit a while ago but insists on
having some anyway to take the edge off
but now we can see her back on her
addiction which is pretty sad to see
considering she was clean for years but
judy talks to michael about changing
clouds and its policies immediately she
wants the tiger claws out of clouds
making the moxes take over even though
in the conditions and what happened with
evelyn michael was very stubborn and a
real [ __ ] about it before you leave
you can choose to kill evelyn's rapist
which is very satisfying judy's new plan
is to develop combat ai to help fight
against people who get handsy with the
workers it's clearly effective as tom
knocks us on her ass the plan is to take
clouds over by force now
starting with the boss this becomes a
choice you have two
original options go with judy's plan or
go with michael's plan michael has a
secret motive she wants to run clouds as
she knows that the tiger claws value
strength and won't take this lost
sitting down
judy's plan is just overtaking clouds
with new management from the mocks this
then sprouts into three options
judy's plan michael's plan in accepting
her payment afterwards or michael's plan
without accepting any payment if you
accept judy's plan you can continue to
the end mission and possibly get a
romance but you find out that clouds was
overrun by the tiger claws again and tom
and some of the other workers died in
the crossfire if you accept michael's
plan
and payment you can't get the ending
with judy and the quest stop here then
there's of course the middle ground
where you do michael's plan but you
don't accept payment for it judy doesn't
like it but is okay with the option and
you can still get the end mission and
romancer if you choose this option
michael gets to run clouds and judy
isn't really too happy with it but she's
okay with it
although the only negative though is
that she does mention that some of the
workers have complained that whether it
was hiromi or michael running things
nothing really changed which is quite
sad to see as all of this was for
nothing assuming you chose the options
to continue the quest line you get the
ending mission where you and judy
attempt some technology invention
the ability to capture both feelings and
thoughts of two people in a bd something
not possible before as there was just
too much static and white noise that
would interfere
it sounds weird how the quests transfer
from a revolution to this but judy is
and always will be a bd editor so she
wants to make more strides in the
technology if it means more business for
the moxes
this is a pretty calming mission you go
on a deep sea dive to the ruined town
that got flooded and you get to see
judy's old house there was a bill
written not too long ago about a dam
being built and due to the legislation
of it it caused this town to be flooded
and tons of memories are still at the
bottom so judy simultaneously wants to
see her old home
and also help record that bd invention
she had halfway through exploring you
end up collapsing but she happens to
drag you out of the water and save you
you then stop your adventure and have
some coffee at the cottage
if your v is female this is where the
romance comes in and you can sleep
together for the night
if you're male you end up sleeping
separately but remain good friends judy
then has plans to leave night city and
move to oregon and continue her life
away from the [ __ ] of this city
ending her questline
as for her voice lines and the ending
most of them are just her talking about
her time away from night city how it's
the best decisions he's ever made and we
need to do it ourselves for the suicide
ending she's tearing up over our death
which as we know is bad especially for
her considering that is now two friends
that have killed themselves in her
lifetime
before the heist we meet with dexter
deshaun the afterlife but before that
meeting we take a quick stop at the bar
inside and have a couple drinks with
jackie and from there we're introduced
to the bartender claire she engages in
some small talk mentioned how some of
the legends in the afterlife get a drink
named after them
it's a nice little detail you can go
back to the afterlife after jackie's
passing and ask for a jackie wells a
drinking name for himself when we first
visited there
while it is great it said we aren't even
allowed to drink or purchase this though
but claire after some time will call you
and mention how we've been gaining some
traction and that she needs a
professional to help her she wants to
participate in some races and needs a
driver with the promise of there being a
large cash prize at the end
the races are somewhat the same just in
different locations until we get to the
second last race where we hear about a
guy named samson claire's husband used
to race with her and be the driver until
samson caused them to crash which killed
her husband
the race was never about money rather
revenge on samson during the race samson
is constantly outpacing you but at one
point in the race he needs to turn off
the road and get into an accident
if we continue the race and don't follow
samson claire hates us for the rest of
the game but if we turn and chase him we
get more options
if claire kills him we get her unique
card beast but if we convince her to
spare him we get beast and samson's car
a week later when he calls it up it's up
to the player's choice and doesn't
really affect any of the endings in the
first place
claire's questline isn't particularly
long but it is fun as most races are i
just wish we could do more of these in
not just these four
during our heist as we know things went
south quickly and we are dumped in a
landfill thankfully we are saved by
takamura saburo's main guard takabura is
loyal to saburo arasaka and he is his
guard but he has felt betrayed thanks to
yuri noble killing him and framing us
for his crime
we wake up and defend ourselves from the
other arasaka guards yurinobu sent these
guards after us as he was worried we may
expose his secret that he was the true
killer all along so he wanted to
eliminate us and take takamura in the
process
it's from here that we are mobile again
and can meet with takamura to discuss
the plan
we have to find hellman the man who
created the chip and also talk with some
atakamura's contacts
for his contact it's lady hanukko's
bodyguard oda as you would expect it
goes terrible and he doesn't help us in
the slightest the portion with helman is
more for arsake and not his although he
does appreciate it if we do notify him
that we have helmet in our possession as
takamura has some
unanswered questions sakumar's plan was
to talk with lady hanako daughter of
saburo which is why we asked her guard
but since he declined we have to get
more aggressive with it we must
infiltrate a parade starting soon and
cut security so takamura has the
opportunity to discuss the issue at hand
with her in private during this we
encounter oda again in his guard uniform
and if we spare him takamura will thank
us once again since he's just doing his
duty and he shouldn't be involved in
this matter and if we kill them his
death would be a waste hanukkah during
the talk freaks out and takamura results
to tranquilizing and capturing
her so we run from arasaka and meet a
nearby hotel room and while that did
work for a little bit we once again have
been found and ambushed we need to
escape once more and it's also
interesting that the game doesn't give
you this objective but takamura is still
alive and can be saved assuming you're
like me and didn't know that he will die
if not
saved in this hotel room regardless of
what you choose you meet with a proxy
from hanako and discuss a plane which
turns into the end of the game
the only other time he shows up is
during the arasaka ending which we
talked about in the previous video which
is linked in the description and in the
eye on the top right but he does make an
appearance in that ending although it is
very short and insignificant this will
also lead to the achievement called the
devil this ends takamura's questline
it's not an official quest line but
since he's a main character for a short
time i thought it was relevant to at
least
mention especially because takumar is a
fun character to talk to he plays this
old man
character but he doesn't really seem to
understand technology sometimes as one
instance he was googling food but ended
up texting us instead which added some
comedy to his character while takamura
and v
have different policies and opinions
when they work together things for the
most part usually go smoothly and of
course capping dexter was really
satisfying during the mission ghost town
rogue gives us info on hellman the man
who made the biochip rogue only knows
one person who'll be correct for the job
panam palmer a murk who is an ex-nomad
we find her on the outskirts of night
city and we ask her for help but she's
adamant on getting her car back before
we can proceed panama has been in some
heat over her decisions with the clan
the aldecados
they don't trust her too much and she's
completely [ __ ] up rogue's last job
which is why
her car is gone eventually meets
scorpion and mitch two of her close
friends
we quickly pick up a box that will be
helpful for later and we learn a lot
about panam during the drive so
the current leader is not running things
properly in her eyes they moved here
with the promise of a better future and
bigger land but all they got was sand
intense and we also learned that mitch
and scorpion were combat veterans in the
last corporate war to get her car first
we need to stake out an old town where
the new owner of the car will be
handling it either stealthily or guns
blazing we take the keys and give the
card to pan am we just need to do two
things before she does our part of the
job which is killing nash a guy she
despises and to do a trade deal with the
sixth street after helping her it's only
fair that she helps us
and now it's time to find helman we know
that hellman is arriving on a specific
av
here in the outskirts so we gotta take
it down which we do by sabotaging a
corporate power station and emptying the
av
it wasn't effective so we gotta
improvise the chase is on to catch where
it lands mitch and scorpion also see the
explosion and chase after it as well
except they don't know that the kang tal
guards are there and we can't warn them
thanks to the emp
when we clear the area we find out mitch
is thankfully still alive but scorpion
didn't make it
after investigating the crime scene we
follow it to a gas station where we can
finally find helman and question him on
the biochip
this is finally the end of the first
intro mission and we can now continue
panam's questline as usual we get a
phone call from pan am
saul got taken by the wraiths the rates
are the nomads same as the aldocaldos
but they're rogue x nomads saul was out
with a small group and ended up getting
ambushed pan am wants more help with the
operation but the old timers won't help
is they don't care for saul's authority
in order to do this properly we need to
stake out the camp and proceed with the
info we gather we then find saul get him
in the van and drive away the only
problem that arises is the sandstorm
which clouds the vision so we opt to
chill at a nearby abandoned home and
wait it out we can choose to make
advances with pan am here but nothing
comes of it
the next mission involves a heated
debate between saul and pan amiga and
about the basilisk a giant tank panam
wants to steal it
saul thinks it's too risky we of course
agree and accompany pan am to a stop a
train which blocks the path to people
carrying the tank we then kill them and
tank the tank for ourselves we can also
make advances towards her once again but
will also prove unsuccessful it's only
in the next mission where our advances
finally work
pan am and the veterans are talking
about the basilisk we then take it for a
test drive and assuming you're a male v
you can have a romance scene with pan am
but midway through of our session of
love we're attacked by the raffins again
and need to fend them off
fully expecting an argument when panam
returns she meets with saul but
saul accepts her back into the aldi
caldos after having a beer panem tells
us to join the aldo caldos and stay with
them but we clearly got some business
with a biochip to handle first this is
the final mission we do with her besides
the ending pan am is the only
romanceable character in this game that
has her own ending
in this ending we called the aldo caldos
to help us raid arasaka tower
we helped them so they helped us the
plan is a frontal assault through the
defenses with the basilisk and using a
giant drill that's located there to bust
the tower's walls it's a super
entertaining mission with tons of
enemies and constant explosions but
sadly not everything was as exciting as
once you make it inside into the mikoshi
room
adam arrives and kills saul assuming you
chose the v body and get the nomad
ending
us and panim after everything is
finished attempt to leave night city
with the other nomads we have some talks
with pan am here on this lovely set
piece and v brings up how he wants to
find a cure for his problem pan am also
offers to help us and says that some of
her fellow nomads in arizona may know
how to help us
is this a possible dlc hint i'll let you
be the judge of that her voicemails
change more frequently than most
especially if you choose her ending in
both options like we stated in our last
video she is absolutely pissed at johnny
for taking her body over but if we side
with her she calls talking about camp if
we take the suicide route she's actually
super angry at us for it pan am easily
has the longest quest line and one of
the more engaging ones in my opinion
easily the best companion and romance
option in the game
it makes it all more cool if you played
as a nomad from the start as you start
with a nomad then
end is one two which i thought was
pretty cool our last two companions
are the companions that have the romance
options who you may miss since they're
from side missions our first one
is river we get this from the mission i
fought the law from district attorney
perales the mayor of night city passed
away and these two don't believe it was
a simple cyber malfunction and that some
foul play was involved so we go through
a brain dance to gather some information
and context to the situation
in the brain dance we see a man in a
brown coat enter and then a second later
fire on a murderer who's stabbed in
nearby guard
he walks in at the perfect moment almost
too perfect just before the lunatic does
so to gather more evidence
we need to track this man down in the
coat this guy's name is river ward
we learn from river that the cyber
psycho who attempted to attack the mayor
had plans to meet with him but since he
was crazy the cops wanted to question
him at the precinct but he managed to
escape and walk right into the building
without anyone noticing
river knew about this and attempted to
warn the mayor about this incident which
is what we saw on the braindance which
is why he was so perfect in his timing
the only info we have to go off of is
that the late mayor ryan went to a club
called the red queen's race before he
died
problem is we don't know who where or
how he ended up dying
thankfully a friend of rivers knows the
location red queen's race is a club
owned by the animals the local gang
and once inside we find a used bd wreath
on the floor when we put it on it fries
our systems and almost kills us
thankfully river was there to assist but
now we know what caused the killing
looking at the camera footage we see
detective han from earlier at the scene
of the crime it seems someone hacked the
bd to kill the mayor when detective han
reported it he talked about changing the
narrative and not telling the actual
truth we confront han that we know what
he's up to but he's very calm about the
situation considering the fact
we can't do [ __ ] to him thanks to the
way the people of this city work which
makes it harder for river to bring him
to justice but at least the case gets
opened up again
sadly we can't pursue this any further
regardless though river thanks us for
our assistance which finishes the intro
quest line
later he calls us and needs our help he
shows us some news footage of a man
named anthony being shot by cops as he
was found with a dead body in his car
while it's intriguing already it's
discovered that river's nephew randy was
taken by an anthony and
anthony was spotted wearing randy's
shoes except we have no clue where
anthony took randy and now that anthony
is in a vegetative state we have no
leads
this was then opened up in a case but it
makes sense that river wasn't on the
case due to him possibly being too
emotionally invested in the case seeing
as it's his nephew but the person that
was assigned to the case hasn't gotten
anywhere which is why he takes it into
his own hands
we then track down a building where
anthony's dreams could be while we
explore we find some interesting easter
eggs and while doing so we're caught by
one of the workers so we head to a
relative's house joss who was randy's
mom we do this so we can find evidence
from randy's side as opposed from
anthony's to see if anything connects or
give us some clues
on his computer we find a video of a cow
being drained for its milk anthony lured
randy in because of his troubled pasts
anthony's father was abusive to him and
randy's dad died in his early life so
they both had trouble childhoods anthony
used this to lure randy into his trap he
also found randy's ip address which he
probably figured out where he was from
there there's some digging on anthony's
website we can see the cow video again
and how it relates
through the use of a bd we can get into
the mind of anthony as a child he was
tormented by his teachers and his father
his father was a farmer who would
constantly yell at him over the smallest
things we see this keep a hold of him
mentally as he still watches the same
video of the cow and his mind floods
with those terrible memories he sees a
person attempting to escape but catches
them before they can leave but more
notably we see the devices these people
are hooked up to the same ones the cows
were using back when he was a kid he's
treating the boys like their cattle we
have all the info that we need and now
know the place that he could be
once inside the farm we look around for
a way to stop the gas and break the
people out luckily we find randy amongst
the victims that are able to save him
river is happy with this conclusion but
not yet as he wants to get revenge by
actually killing anthony we can opt to
help him but he says it's something he
has to handle on his own the last quest
we receive from river is to come by the
house we get to enjoy a nice family
dinner we find out that randy is still
in intensive care but he's recovering
and that river decided not to kill
anthony as it seemed more like an
execution than a simple killing and it
just didn't sit right with his
conscience we then enjoy some quality
family time like playing vr with the
kids eating food together and drinking
some beers in the water tower
assuming your v is female you can then
romance river here but other than that
it's just two dudes drinking and
relaxing he then gives you his gun as a
reward and ending the questline for his
voice
it's mostly about the crimes he's been
up to except in the suicide ending where
he pays his respects and says that a
buddy of his did the same thing when the
higher-ups and the force weren't
treating him right i've always been a
fan of murder mystery quests in any type
of rpg game and i like the new
implications of the new technology
of bds to help find clues so this is a
really fun quest line to do the last
companion and romance partner for the
video is carrie eurodyne we're
introduced to carrie during the samurai
questline with jonny and rogue carrie
wants to get samurai back together for
one last gig
assuming you do this he will then send
you a text where you can start his
separate quest line
when you meet carrie again he talks
about some sabotage the popular japanese
girl group
us cracks are having a concert soon and
we're here to sabotage the concert and
cancel it by destroying their equipment
this is because us cracks are doing a
remix of one of carrie's songs and he's
not happy about it
so we spiked the road and blow the van
up destroying the gear we then take a
trip to the local coffee shop not only
to celebrate but learn about the past of
samurai apparently the band would always
go to this place all the time even if
they had no money as it was dirt
cheap sadly this didn't solve anything
as they didn't cancel the gig they just
merely postponed it so now we gotta talk
to them in person by sneaking in we get
a private discussion with the group
except things become a little twisted we
discovered that they had true passion
for carrie's music and that the label
wanted them to make the remix the label
[ __ ] them both over he apologizes then
takes a photo with them for the memories
things started pretty wild but ended
pretty tame which is real nice
sometime later we meet carrie at this
club and we see that not only have the
us cracks and carry made up they've
actually collaborated on a song together
but something is still eating at him
when we question carrie he mentions that
he doesn't want things to go wrong or
the media to spin the story
old irrelevant rocker boy helps asian
pop group and attempts to be relevant
again he doesn't want that kind of
attitude or attention towards him as
that's not true he also just doesn't
want to be in another person's shadow
again
people have always remembered johnny
silverhand from samurai not so much
carrie that's why he left samurai in the
beginning
oscarax has also gained tons more
attention than carrie has and he doesn't
want that to happen again thanks to the
label and how easy it is to manipulate
the music industry it could quite
possibly happen so he's very scared
about it you can then kiss carrie and
tell him everything's going to be all
right and you can get closer to the
romance our last mission is carrie
inviting us on a boat for a drive and
some hangout he sits there making music
while we take a load off he then smashes
the rare guitar right in front of us
turns out this isn't his boat or his
guitar it's kovacs the label guy who
[ __ ] carrie over so he trashed the
[ __ ] out of his boat throwing records
paintings coffee machines and
it's at this point where you can fully
romance with carrie this then starts the
cutscene at which point he lights the
boat on fire in the middle of things and
once the fire spreads too much we dip
out while it's all on fire
we then sit on the beach watching the
boat explode then sink to the bottom
finishing the quest line carrie's
questline was actually pretty fun
blowing [ __ ] up is never boring and it
was a nice resolution to the questline
for his voicemails at the ending he
talks about the collab with us cracks
and how everything worked out okay in
the end in the suicide ending he's like
pan am he's very angry at us
especially since as we know a rumor
about kerry attempting to kill himself
spread like wildfire in the media and he
understands the attention and negativity
that can bring
and is mad at us for doing so this then
ends our companions deep dive video
like i said the cyberpunk videos are
only just beginning as i got more on the
way
a full johnny deep dive cyber psychosis
the future of the story tons more so
stay subscribed to the channel for all
that future content but with that all
settled thank you for watching the video
and i'll see you in a future story video
goodbye and take care
[Music]
you